venomous snakes have long held our
imaginations in
thrall and it makes sense to this day
humans fall prey to their natural
defenses
secretive slithering seductive and scary
the serpent has claimed
a prominent place in our literature art
religion
and even natural history and there are
few serpents more frightening or
pervasive
than the king of snakes the mighty
basilisk
i'm sure for some of you when you see
this picture you'll say oh wait that's a
cockatrice
well you're not wrong that's right the
elusive and terrifying snake monster and
the fiery rooster monster
not only share origins but are arguably
the same monster
just with two different names this
this and this are all the same creature
technically even this little one but
we'll get to that cutie later
join me on an exploration of the
basilisk cockatrice connection
and how it went from frightening snake
to a metaphor for pure
evil i'm dr emily zarka
and this is monstrum the earliest
references to the serpentine monster
date back
thousands of years to the first century
in his epic poem for salia the roman
poet marcus anayus lukanus
known in english as luken introduced us
to a serpent capable of producing
immense terror writing the basilisk
which pours forth hisses terrifying all
beasts
which harms before its poison and orders
the entire crowd
far out of its way and on the empty sand
is king
with a stroke of his pen lucan brought
to life a terrifying snake
whose royal status was firmly
established from the beginning
so lethal the basilisk venom can kill
even after the beast has been destroyed
as a soldier in farsalia learns when he
stabs the snake
and the venom runs up the spear into his
hand in a moment of foresight the man
slices off his own hand with a sword to
save his life
pliny's encyclopedic historia naturalis
or natural history
contains a similar story only this time
both the rider and his horse
die after the basilisk is speared in
this text
the blackish yellow no more than foot
long snake
slithers along with its upper body erect
hypnotizing its prey with eyes sunken
into a sharp head
according to pliny the basilisk can kill
with its gaze alone
as well as with its noxious breath
interestingly we also learn of the
monster's weakness
the stench of a weasel will kill the
basilisk although the weasel too
will perish pliny asserts that the
basilisk earns its greek name
vasaliskos and latin equivalent
basiliscus
both meaning kinglet for a crown-like
white spot on its sharp head resembling
a diadem
in fact those two early texts farsalia
and historia naturalis
laid the foundation for the attributes
that have been associated with the
basilisk
ever since that is a venomous snake
whose breath gaze or even hiss
could destroy all life animal human or
vegetable moreover the origin stories of
the basilisk include mention of an
ability to summon
other snakes with hiss even as it
frightens off or kills
all other creatures it's unsurprising
then that this powerful decorated snake
with its crown-like
spot would be subsequently called the
king of the serpents
in the greek poet nycander's theriaka
authors and artists in the medieval
period seem to have taken liberty with
the kinglet
depicting the creature with a crown or
even a rooster's comb
beginning in the 13th century we find
text describing a reptilian monster
and even the king of serpents with all
of the traits of the basilisk
plus a new one a rooster's comb rather
than a crown adorns its head and it
bears a new name
the cockatrice over time we see the
names basilisk and the cockatrice
used interchangeably as the creature
becomes more and more of a snakebird
hybrid
the cockatrist appears in literature and
art in marginalia and coat of arms
bearing a combination of chicken and
reptilian features
with dragon wings or an extra head
occasionally thrown in there for good
measure
it is said to petrify with its gaze or a
touch of its beak
with all this fantastic and suggestive
imagery around its appearance
it's no surprise that religions would
embrace its wealth of allegorical power
in the christian tradition the serpent
was already associated with sin
and the devil due largely to its
seductive role in the fall of the garden
of eden
so the basilisk aka the cockatrice
didn't really stand a chance
take for example an origin story of the
basilisk that emerged in the 1100s
which proposed that it is born from an
egg hatched by a toad
the first person to suggest this was
saint hildegard in her book physica
she even goes as far as to say it is the
diabolic art of the ancient
serpent that comes from the antichrist
that spawns this unnatural hatching
over time these dubious origins become
part of the basilisk and the cockatrice
myths
evolving even further to include details
like the egg is laid by a rooster
and that it would be incubated in a dung
heap the basilisk became
not just dangerous and poisonous but a
literal embodiment of
evil that must be vanquished in fact a
lot of art from the medieval period
shows christ
a saint or some other holy figure
defeating the basilisk or cockatrice
but it can still be killed by a weasel
which explains these absolutely
delightful illustrations
and of course given the shift towards
religious allegory and the history of
the serpent beast
we see the power of prayer taking hold
as another defense against its evil
effects
a bit confusingly around this time we
learn that carrying a rooster around can
also protect you
because the rooster's crow can frighten
the basilisk to death
or if you're quick on your feet spotting
the basilisk before it spots you or
showing it its own reflection
are among your defensive options oh yes
the idea that humans could survive the
deadly gaze of the basilisk by looking
at it in a mirror had begun to take hold
so apparently harry potter got that part
correct even though voldemort's basilisk
is much much much larger than any other
depiction of a basilisk in literature or
art that's artistic license for you
interestingly the deadly gaze of the
monster along with its more negative
associations with sin
and evil and christianity eventually led
to its allegorical use to indicate both
vile scoundrels and dangerously
beautiful and seductive women
in the 17th century and beyond which
likely goes back to the portrayal of eve
in the garden of eden
although there are many other plausible
contributing factors including the myths
of medusa and the llamia
along with you know patriarchy john
dryden famous english poet and
playwright of the 17th century was one
such
author the queen in the spanish friar or
the double discovery
is called the basilisk of tourismund
since she kills with her eyes
but let's go back to those early origins
of the basilisk there are scholars who
argue that the basilisk of ancient lore
was actually a real snake
that with time and the human imagination
was imbued with
more and more traits until it became
something utterly fantastical
and completely divorced from its mundane
roots if it is true as some assert that
the early basilisk at one point was
believed to be native to libya this
makes sense
after all libya is home to the egyptian
cobra
one of the most terrifying snakes on the
planet cobras are also illustrated in
egyptian hieroglyphics with the middle
of the body raised up
in a manner that resembles bird feet
which might have later contributed to
the cockatrice interpretation of the
monster
and which calls to mind pliny's
description of the basilisk's erect
upper body
while the egyptian cobra is a perfectly
serviceable real-life origin snake for
our evil serpent
it is not the only candidate for the
honor another theory
i offer you the humble grass snake the
grass snake has a yellow orange or white
collar
and its defensive mechanisms include
aggressively hissing
secreting a foul-smelling substance from
the anal glands and even playing dead
grass snakes also happen to love to
hatch their eggs in rotting wood
plant debris compost and dung heaps
what's most interesting about the grass
snake as real basilisks theory
is that grass snakes while totally
common are
rarely mentioned in ancient bestiaries
and early animal encyclopedias
meanwhile the fictional basilisk is
identified as a species in almost
every one of these resources this might
indicate that the grass snake was at one
point misidentified as a basilisk
before the latter's evolution to the
cockatrist blurred the lines between
reality and fiction even more
to make this even more interesting the
cox egg origins of the basilisk
cockatrice could be explained by the
perfectly normal phenomenons of hens
occasionally laying
yokeless eggs or hens acting like
roosters because of a hormone imbalance
or an unusually dominant personality
then there's the occasional appearance
of parasitic worms and eggs
which will sometimes look like tiny
snakes whether or not the basilisk aka
the cockatrice was truly based on a real
animal is unclear what we do know is
that we
humans have been fascinated with the
idea of the basilisk for centuries
so much so that they have permeated into
our literature and art
to this day the basilisk and cockatrists
live on in books d
video games and film and coming full
circle from its vaguely reptilian
associations
there are real modern lizards named
after this fantastic beast
four species of lizards in fact they are
in the iguana day family in the genus
basiliscus better known as cask head
lizards
their common names include the brown or
striped basilisk
the western basilisk the common basilisk
and the plumed lizard
whom you may also recognize as the jesus
lizards for their ability to run across
water this seems particularly ironic
given the basilisk one-time association
with the devil
while these lizards have no powers that
allow them to cause death with a glance
they do have a long tail and an
elongated head
that looks like a rooster's comb just
another way monster history infiltrates
our real world
the basilisk and the cockatrice have
thrived in our imaginations for a very
long time from
king of the serpents to sin incarnate to
a metaphor for the exaggerated dangers
of a woman's allure
these serpentine avian monsters both
fascinate and repel
their lethal gaze lingering from the
pages of antiquity into our modern world
have you ever wondered what makes words
well words
other words pbs's newest show about
language and linguistics has you covered
other words dives into languages around
the world to uncover the fascinating
unexpected and sometimes weird stories
behind the human trait we all take for
granted
check out other words right here on
storied